Chris long the Eagles defensive end
played with the Eagles still playing
with the Eagles got a Super Bowl ring
played with the Patriots and good to
have Chris back on the show are you an
RV guy do you have a you have a camper I
do I actually coming bears has two
campers two campers yeah so I had a 1992
dodge coachman for a lot of years and
then I just upgraded recently to this
nice shiny like Mercedes Sprinter dad
van but I don't have the heart to sell
my old coachman do you pack up the
family and drive cross-country uh I've
been known to to be a little road
warrior but my kids aren't old enough to
really do that yet but I'm excited to
take them camping and whatnot so they're
almost there you're not retired are you
not currently no are you I'm relaxed you
know I hope so I mean I you know like I
feel I feel really good I had I had a
good year and you know I don't feel old
but you know that goes it's a ma I'm
only gonna I'm gonna weigh my options
and and she you know what my
opportunities are like in Philly and and
and go from there I know there was a lot
made of the anonymous sources talking
about Carson Wentz as a quarterback what
you know let's let's check that one off
the list here knock it out what did you
make it yeah well I mean like listen I
did that story really blew up I mean
there was never a quarterback
controversy in our building you know
even after the Super Bowl and Nick went
on that magical run I mean everybody
knows the franchise QB is now like
outside the building if you go on the
internet you can read all types of takes
and theories um and then you know you
you you got an anonymously sourced
article that's a little bit disparaging
and in my opinion very untrue that kind
of refers to you know I think was four
to six people in the building I don't
know if they're necessarily players but
by and large everybody that's come out
and spoken out has been in unanimous
support of Carson and that's kind of to
me that was all news to me you know what
I mean
Carson is the best teammate you could
ask for and he's a guy who battled
through injuries all year and everybody
has supported him he's been supportive
of Nick
we have a special locker room and I
didn't think those anonymous sources
which I'm not a real big fan of that
whole thing anyways real representative
of what the locker room Saints any
chance the Eagles keep both Wentz and
foals I don't know what's next contract
situation I honestly haven't paid much
attention you know if they keep him they
owe him 20 and I think he can buy his
way out for two million and they could
franchise tag him as well I I would be I
would try to keep both at least for one
more year that that's what I would do
you know yeah you know but if if Nick
did walk and you had that 20 million
laying around you could like invest in
the d-line you mean give it to you no I
mean Nick Nick if Nick walks I mean like
admit go somewhere else like he's gonna
succeed he's gonna be he's gonna be
successful I think there's a number of
places he could for either yeah it's
just the way it is I mean it's it's one
of those things that if he weren't so
good you you'd think it'd be a little
easier to keep him but I wouldn't blame
somebody if you wanted to go be the guy
you know we're talking to Chris long
the Eagles defensive lineman joining us
Dan Patrick show I'm curious when you
faced the Patriots last year does Doug
Peterson say Chris I need all the intel
on the Patriots since you played there
did you have one of those where you say
let me have a here's a debriefing on the
Patriot yeah yeah I mean you know that's
kind of the way of the world in the NFL
I mean you know you got guys that teams
will sign off practice squad from other
teams and try to you know see what what
they know and that's just kind of what
it is and having played for them before
and I did it the Year previous when I
was with the Patriots in plays to the
RAM
the year before that so you know you you
give a little intel on what you know
personnel laws and whatnot but you know
somebody who's as great a game planning
and and as good a coach's dog or Bill I
mean they don't need much help from me
or any other players and and when you're
talking about the Patriots one thing
that makes them so good is you know I
know they have this reputation of being
rigid and having a an identity but their
identity changes to suit whatever game
or situation they're playing and you
know it's a perfect example like the
playoffs right now they've morphed into
this smash mouth team I think they ran
for like a buck 80 last week
those big tackles they've got their own
lines playing real well and you know
they change from week to week they
change from season to season playoff to
playoff and that's what makes Bill so
good was there a play in the Super Bowl
against the Patriots where you're kind
of smiled and you said I know what's
going to happen I just think it was a
cumulative effect of the way our offense
was rolling we knew it was gonna be a
shootout and we had to we had to survive
Tom a little bit I mean we kept him in
check in the first half and then they
came out and made some adjustments and
started feeding broth and they were
rolled and it was it was a little
terrifying for a little bit because we
couldn't get a stop and you know we we
bailed the offense out before the the
offenses bailed us out before and and
that day was kind of it was kind of the
offense been out on us out but all we
had to do was create that one turnover
and that's what we did at the end of the
game and you know there was that
possession and then they had another
shot right after that to drive in about
a minute you know the length of the
field so we made two stops there and and
yeah I mean it was it was a magical day
the situation we had in New Orleans over
the weekend with the non called there
and I think we can all agree that it was
a bad call my I guess I'm wondering why
the Commissioner hasn't spoken out about
why hasn't he got in front of the camera
do you think the Commissioner owes that
to the league to the fans to at least
address this in what we saw yeah I think
Benjamin Watson put it what
pretty well I mean there's gonna be bad
calls those officials have a hard job
but this league has always been adaptive
and this league is always I'm hit the
curveball and try to improve the product
on the field so I don't know if it's a
function of I'm not you know settling on
what the mo is going to be what the plan
of attack is gonna be and not wanting to
contradict what's gonna happen in the
future by releasing the statement but I
remember when I was a kid you grew up
watching football if it was a bad call
just a bad call and you know when replay
came along you know everybody said this
is gonna be terrible for the game it
slowing the game down at what point does
it stop and now I think nobody bats an
eye I mean we go to replay five times a
game I think everybody's pretty happy we
wouldn't want to go the other way so I
think not only should they be talking
about it but they should be taking some
action I understand that P is subjective
but some some situations are not
subjective when interpreting that rule
and I think that was one of them did you
come up with a an app that is
challenging uber and lyft or are you
complimenting goober and lyft
I'm worse we're complementing and when I
say we it's this group Freebird I'm
working with it's like a cash back
rewards app for all your brand lift
rides and I'm going to use another time
like being introduced to it and
representing it I'm going to use it to
stay you know worryfree and safe when
I'm going to all the parties this week
and you know basically the concept is
that if you download the app it's going
to give you credit towards rides on uber
and lyft at certain functions in the
spirit of keeping people safe it
incentivizes people not to make stupid
stupid decisions like drive drunk you
know if you download that for free and
enter my promo code please enter that
promo code in particular go long you'll
get ten dollars towards your first ride
and this weekend at the Super Bowl you
know because everybody loves to throw a
few back and myself included Super Bowl
Sunday you get $10 first year towards
your ride to a Super Bowl party and $10
towards your ride back from the Super
Bowl party so
you know it's a no-brainer I mean it's
it's at this point in in 2019 you know
why would you get behind the wheel when
you've had something to drink there's no
conceivable reason and they're doing a
great job of incentivizing people to
stay safe yeah it's a free bird is the
mobile app and promo code is go long so
you get paid to party at the Superbowl
is that what you're saying yeah it's
different in the last few years but uh
you know with well with those playoffs
checks and I'd obviously rather be in
the Superbowl book you know players make
a lot more money off the field than they
do on the field during the during the
Superbowl now you uh we talked to you
what your rookie year and you had an old
wasn't an Impala like a tricked-out
Impala was that right yes my rookie year
I had in 1983 Mercury Grand Marquis and
I put I put suicide doors on it you know
because I thought it was kind of funny
and and I was given an old teammate of
mine Darrell Scott from Clemson a ride
home and we were getting on the
interstate you know you when you get on
an on-ramp some of them a real circular
and the car is leaning around the corner
and he's sitting on the left side and
the doors flip over to the seatbelt and
we're going 40 miles an hour and I said
I got a I got a turn this car in so I
sold it to it I sold it to a dare
officer and and he and he used it as his
dare car I didn't even know there were
still dare officers oh that's cool yeah
you since upgraded since then III think
I'm also ask your dad about this that
you know when fight choose to break out
with you your brother Kyle who plays for
the Bears like there's some big boys
around there but like like who's the 1
seed with your dad Howie then you and in
Kyle
well I think Kyle's the 1 seed I mean
he's 6 foot 7 340 pounds and that's if
he didn't eat for 3-4 days and and he's
and he's got he's got you know like abs
like he's he's like the mountain from
Game of Thrones
and I would say I'm probably the to seat
by you know because my dad's almost 60
years old now he's had 12 operations I
think you know a 33 year old alley long
is the one seat but he slides down to
three and I think I might be four I
think my youngest brother Howie junior
he'll do anything to win so yeah yeah
would your dad cheap shot you
what do you cheap shot me um if he
wasn't me or if he wasn't fighting me I
think he keep it fair with me cuz yeah
we got this understanding this mutual
respect but what's he had 12 sir your
dad still looks great his hair still
looks great you know he looks awesome he
lives pretty clean you know so he he
looks good and I don't think his joint
seal is good but you put him in a suit
and you get him there at the desk and he
looks he looks like he could still roll
is he critical how critical is your dad
of your play and your brothers play uh I
think I think he's just honest and that
that's a real tool like I think I
appreciate that I'm in a unique
situation where my dad knows exactly
what I was thinking on every play and he
knows you know I might walk out of a
game and everybody's patting me on the
back but I know I didn't play that well
maybe I had a sack or two but I didn't
play that well and he knows and
conversely you know after game where I
don't show up on the statute a lot but I
really played well you know he knows
that I played well and it's just a nice
person to have in your corner who
understands it and he's really helped me
a lot through my career in
decision-making and and develop them
again we're not sure if he's playing
again next year
but he's Chris long you can also like
I'd like to I'd like to okay I'd like to
so yeah so yeah so many teams are
listening Chris long would like to build
Pauley can we give out Chris's phone
number here yeah we'll post it yeah by
the way the mobile app for all your uber
and
lift rides is Freebird and if you use
the promo code go long $10 towards your
next where your first free bird ride and
also kind of complimenting uber and lyft
certainly during the Superbowl as well
Chris good to talk to you everybody stay
safe check out stay safe
check out the app guys appreciate it Dan
it's great talking to you as well
hope the family's good and maybe we'll
cross paths in Atlanta thank you
yes sir see you there all right that's
not Chris alone for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]